poco a poco el nuevo ejecutivo de Brasil
va tomando forma este viernes el
presidente electo Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva anunció sus primeros cinco
ministros que lo ayudarán a gobernar a
partir de enero
Yo diría que son personas con
cualificación y cualidades para
desempeñar las funciones que les fueron
asignadas
entre los más conocidos
y exministro de Educación que pasará a
ocupar la cartera de Hacienda amigo
cercano de Lula y líder del partido de
los trabajadores mientras el
expresidente estaba en la cárcel
compitió contra bolsonaro por la
presidencia en 2018 y ahora vuelve al
ejecutivo
reconstruyamos Brasil Juntos por el
camino del desarrollo y de la justicia
social a cargo del Ministerio de
relaciones exteriores a Mauro vieira
conocido por estar al frente de esta
cartera Durante los dos últimos años de
gobierno de Dilma Rousseff y en defensa
José mucio exdirector del al final de
cuentas un hombre clave para el gobierno
de Lula por sus buenas relaciones con
las fuerzas armadas claramente
posicionadas con yahirra bolsonaro los
ministerios de justicia y presidencia
serán dirigidos por Flavio Dino y Rubí
Costa respectivamente Dino es
actualmente senador y fue gobernador de
la región de marañao y Costa es
gobernador de bahía y uno de los
fundadores del partido de los
trabajadores un anuncio acompañado de
una promesa más diversidad en su
gabinete
vamos a tener mujeres vamos a tener
hombres vamos a tener negros vamos a
tener indígenas vamos a intentar armar
un gobierno que represente a la sociedad
brasileña plenamente
ahora se espera que Lula cierre el
número total de ministerios este domingo
y anuncie a todos sus ministros
aproximadamente